I was a
fighter I ain't
anymore what kind of price you got on me
time that'll get you chased down no
matter where you
go I had your money big mama so is it I
lost it the only way for you to get me
paid is the oldfashioned way fight or
don't fight you might get hurt if you do
you will get hurt if you
[Music]
don't just take it I don't want it it's
the type of money that could change
somebody's life son of a gun the butcher
standing right here in front of me after
all these years you still fighting I
am the lady at the store said you were a
fighter that right once upon a time why
do you have to fight tonight long story
you ain't no good to me dead but you
going to give me a fight you in a big
hole it got bigger when you saw that
dancing around Big Mama's
Street you can't fight it's
done you don't got to do this it's going
to be all
right there is this great big world out
there and sometimes it spins against
you but sometimes it spins you right
into what you
need I can't tell you what you want to
hear that guy will kill you but I'm not
leaving
you you used to be hell but
hell has caught
[Music]
[Applause]
up
yeah it's going to be a battle come
on you don't look capable no more
capable of
what